america was like screw communism
but now it's kind of just the government
and it seems like uh in the background
they're like screw communism but the the
average person you talk to like a ut
college student they don't give a [ __ ]
about communism
yeah i mean why do we hate it so much
do you think it represents
the next step in human
society and people don't want to admit
it
perhaps that's the race between china
and america communism versus capitalism
i mean
communism is just an idea
i mean
it stands for community
instead of capital so it's like instead
of just thinking about capital
well why don't we think about the whole
community
and like it's so vague you know like
everyone
uh
every anything can be called communism
like oh you're having a bake sale that's
communism
or capitalism depending on your
definition but like yeah like you're
helping people eat or your health
helping people get a dentist
or a hospital it's like since we label
everything communism we don't do basic
things to help our our community because
that's communism the only thing that you
can do is profit
so if you can't just help people
uh
you can't just help people you got to
find a way to make money off of helping
people and so that we just [ __ ]
ourselves and and now we don't help our
community because we think that's
communism
so it's like
a self-defeating mentality to just be
like never do communism don't
give
homeless people food or don't help build
houses after katrina that's that's
communism and it's just like it's not
realistic or right it's not smart and
the people who try to i guess serve the
community without worrying about the
dollar kind of go under pretty fast
yeah it's not a sustainable uh business
model to help people
because then someone who makes a lot of
money from it will i'll compete you and
outbid you and destroy you in the
competition
but
i'm curious to see what you think about
the
a show that promotes capitalism like
shark tank what do you think about that
i mean i think it's great to help
innovation and help
new ideas and inventions but i don't
know if that's capitalism
because capitalism is about people who
own capital
uh making more money which i guess
they're doing but they're also helping
uh you know like
people become capitalists
so i guess it's it's good
but yeah i mean uh
people say that there's more innovation
under capitalism but i don't know if
that's true because
oh dude yeah well disney keeps on buying
company after company yeah they destroy
competition yeah yeah
and it's all about profit so like if you
have a
an idea for an invention you can't work
on it you got to work in mcdonald's
and work for the real capitalists so
then all the human labor goes towards
making people who are rich already rich
and then you don't have time to innovate
and think of new ideas
but uh yeah i mean i love shark tank i
think that
i think it's like [ __ ] up to like
think of things like capitalist or
communist because then it's like such a
black and white view of the world it
should be like oh this is good we should
do this even though it's
capitalistic
you know like oh people are coming up
with new ideas let's help them i don't
think that's a bad thing in a way kill
tony seems like the comedy version of
shark tank promoting comedy and then
kind of like defusing the whole art form
let's hear your one minute pitch
and then be like i can give you 10
steak in my company i got a hot bid on
midgets hans how much you want to put
into that how much you're willing to
steal that joke for a [ __ ] joke
yeah what if that's just how tony comes
up with his hour he just goes on kill
tony and steals everyone's best bits
that'll be great we'll know if he steals
my selling salt bit
we're not on kill tony right now
i've had a lot of people tell me
they'd be like
chris since you look like hans wouldn't
it be funny if you went up as him one
time and just wore his glasses
why is your face so red are you are you
tanned
oh because you drank it's the watermelon
yeah nice and red well you're [ __ ] up
right now maybe if i drink this mango
i'm gonna go back to yellow back to
normal
so uh yeah what do you think about this
podcast studio you think it could be
good a good thing you could do a lot of
podcasts from here
yeah of course dude you got like the the
red hexagons it almost looks like uh the
red power ranger in here white and then
red
yeah i need more of them they're so
expensive it's like 40 bucks for just
these are you serious how much is the
black thing like the fluffy thing oh i
don't know is that better i i just see
it in every podcast studio so i assume
that's like the norm almost like a short
microphone yeah i should have got that i
was thinking they have these blankets
i could just hang up blankets
be cheaper yeah do that yeah buy like
little curtains shouldn't be more than
like 200 bucks yeah
just cover this place with curtains holy
crap so you spent one
no no they're all 40 bucks oh
oh yeah
it's not that bad but if i want to cover
this whole place in that thing yeah
but it helps it used to be a lot more
echoey in here
oh it's good
yeah
definitely find a sound guy
are you doing everything yourself yeah
all audio okay
yeah i'd love to find a sound guy
someone who's like just sam who's been
helping you at your dating show yeah
he's good with sound
yeah
he could help but it's just another
person this is so simple like i have all
the gear it takes me a little while but
once i start doing it it'll i'll get
better at it too
then i won't need more people even
though in china that's what they have is
more people
they just use people for shortage though
they're running they didn't keep the
girls so now all the guys are horny
yeah that's the wrong move uh yeah
that's the wrong move you want one guy
to every 10 girl because then that guy
can [ __ ] them all
but if you have 10 girls everyone's
happy uh 10 guys and only one girl she
can only get pregnant like seven times
in her life
maybe that's how they curb population
then it is a problem just get rid of
women chicken in the egg situation
yeah now limit the women
limit women
lemon women you think that we'd do all
right if we were in china
would would we be able to find some some
[ __ ]
depends on what our job is aren't they
really superficial
no no china loves comedy the free speech
on stage in beijing dude they'll love it
yeah
i mean it's crazy how far they got
without any individual liberties it's
like wow people can't invent [ __ ] even
if like
you know
it's not set up for it or like even if i
don't know i guess it's just all about
studying there like you study a lot and
then you get to work on vr or
genetic research or whatever the next
apple phone the iphone yeah everybody i
went to a college with a bunch of
chinese immigrants all of them were like
i'm never going back
why because it's so hard they have to
work so much basically yeah i uh it's
not it's not china but my friend my dad
has a friend
in thailand his kid makes 30 000 baht a
month
which ends up being like
300
and that's like comfortable
yeah
which is wild to me dude
is that a sad story or is that a story
about how little money it costs to live
in thailand that's how much it costs to
live like a decent life
that's like the equivalent of like
50k over there
so it's like not a sh not a good not a
good way to live
i bet if you're that poor then it sucks
because like you might be able to live
rich in thailand but like you can tell
in subtle ways like oh it takes it costs
way too much to buy like alcohol from
america like a miller lite i bet it's
like super expensive there
and you don't have access to all the
things that you see on video
in thailand
yeah no i don't think they restricted
that much maybe stuff about the
government but everything else like you
can still watch like two girls one cup i
think that's well yeah i'm not talking
about that i'm talking about like
imports or like lamborghinis and stuff
yeah yeah mercedes there cost like 300k
just for like a standard whatever
yeah in korea like foreign imports are
really expensive
so they just make luxury hyundais
just make it in-house
that's a good idea to just make things
yourself so you don't have to get it
from elsewhere
i uh
it's funny that we're talking about asia
i've been learning about a lot of comics
like black comics like middle eastern
comics who have like a comedy troupe
would you ever consider going to asia to
do shows
[Music]
maybe
it just feels like a weird thing to do
like uh
you know i need other people
you know like let's get it together and
let's be less lonely together and we can
go around and be friends
it just seems like
like they're more interested in just
hanging out with other people and
finding commonalities than they are with
actually performing and doing stand-up
like middle eastern people are like were
the shaws of comedy or whatever yeah
yeah
bernie mac was only kings of comedy
yeah
what if we were autistic about comedy
and we were like we're not gonna talk
until an hour before the show
and we're just like only it's only about
the bits
yeah i mean it'd be weird if you brought
something up and then everyone was like
why did you bring that up
i feel like that's what asians do
they're like why are you doing that
right now yeah
they're like always questioning why
you're talking
so you have to have a really good reason
to be talking
but in america everyone's just always
talking
so it's not really about like
why you talked but if you can make it
good and create
positive
spikes and energy that everyone this is
all about like shooting the [ __ ] and
like and basically just like riffing
having fun
yeah podcasting yeah yeah i mean it's
like having conversations publicly
it's like a private conversation done
for public com consumption
it's weird because it's like we're
supposed to be just talking to each
other and connecting but we're also
doing it for other people right
look how well we talk to each other we
talk real good dude
does your thing's like smelling that
[ __ ] makes you more like more
in your feelings and less in your
thoughts
no this connects the brain and the heart
someone gave us 50 mexican dollars
that's what like a buck 50.
i don't know
that's pretty nice though i haven't
really gotten paid
to smell this yet
i guess it's going to you
um stand up advice i would say just keep
doing it and improve as a person and
just constantly write jokes and then
find out which jokes work well for you
and keep taking risks and keep bombing
and finding out which
jokes
are good for your style and which jokes
work
um
yeah so uh
yeah i mean i think like
we should
uh not fight each other so much
i think because of like history like
people are more adversarial
like china is fighting america it's not
like a group effort
and it makes sense because like look how
the world was conquered it wasn't a very
peaceful or
a hospitable thing that was done right
it was profit they were just trying to
make as much money and take over as much
[ __ ] as possible so we're we're on that
we're on the wake of that
yeah every guy every rich powerful man
just wants to control the world i think
everybody needs to take shrooms or some
sort of psychedelics because it like
snaps you out of that i remember like
being like well like 19 taking shrooms
the first time i wanted to be like an
oil tycoon and like just like own
and like dominate
and then i took shrooms and i was like
no
yeah that seems gross when you're high
on shrooms
yeah
it's like why would i want to do that
that's like horrible
um yeah i mean
shrooms would help that's why they're
illegal
if everybody took shrooms like nobody
would work at mcdonald's
the stand-up comedian population might
like quadruple
yeah we should all pursue our interests
and we should all emphasize the best
parts of humanity and not just our
ability to
load
things or carry things or flip burgers
i remember you told me you got an
engineering degree how long did you work
as an engineer one year
okay that's about the same for me
working in finance
yeah but yeah i mean it's uh
it's like a such a rigged game it's like
why would i want to play this the
ceiling for me in this game is like a
really good cubicle worker
like i don't want to play a game that's
rigged i want to play a game where i can
win and it's not a game that you can win
if you are an engineer it's all mapped
out already they know exactly what
you're going to do
they've seen different types of people
come through this system and they know
how to neutralize you
so you have to be a business guy if you
want to kind of climb up even
yeah you have to be
focused solely on taking [ __ ] over
domination because if you're actually
good at something like engineering then
you're not going to have enough marbles
or attention or energy to
fight off someone is just trying to take
everything over so that's why you can't
just have like a free-for-all because
then it just becomes a base survival
game
people who are actually good at
something are not favored
because you just wasted a bunch of time
and energy
actually getting good at something
it's so sad to hear you say that i think
you're right but like all i want right
now is to get good at comedy just to
build like one true skill i've never had
like a genuine skill school i've been
like
fine whatever good at but like never
cared never been good at anything i'd
give a [ __ ] about yeah that's the norm
i mean you're doing it
you're probably better than most people
a comedy will ever be
like 90 95 of the population
and i mean you just gotta enjoy it like
the [ __ ] people that do it the best
aren't doing it to win and dominate and
take over they're doing it because they
enjoy it and they have fun so
i mean you don't want to be a loser
who's like
failing but enjoys it and loves doing it
you gotta have some sort of success and
some sort of positive feedback
but you can't also just only have that
you also just gotta love the art of it
and love doing it
yeah i i appreciate the compliment that
means a lot i i think i focus on the art
of it too much to where like the
networking and like the schmoozing and
all that that gets in the way
yeah
don't you ever feel like you just want
to do your set chat for like 20 minutes
and then bounce
yeah
all the time that's what i normally do
unless i'm hanging out with joe rogan in
which case i want to hang out with him
as much as possible and soak in every
ounce of his energy what have you
learned from working with joe
um he's uh really good at talking
i try to learn how to talk like him
he's good at energy he's good at like
being himself and just helping people
and
you know he's honest and nice he's not
lying he's not like
you know being like hey
how's your day been what what's your cat
doing now
he's just like he's just himself and
he's also nice he's not like
faking it he doesn't have to fake it to
be nice he can be genuine and nice you
don't have to be fake to be nice
but yeah i just want to do my set and
leave i don't really want to be there
for a long time yeah
what do you think about uh
just like you you're feeling anti-social
you just like want to do your comedy and
leave
not really leave but like uh
just move on to the next place without
feeling like
a flake or like giving out irish
goodbyes i'm just like i just want to go
next place
well yeah you did what you had to do you
made the room feel great instead of like
talking to everyone for
five minutes you talk to them all at
once for five minutes
it's more efficient
and then you leave it's like most people
don't ever talk to everyone at a party
and you just did that so
technically you made more face time than
most people did true true
but yeah i mean it's really a solitary
pursuit you're just doing comedy and
you're working on your craft so whatever
it takes but yeah it's exhausting
especially like socializing and the
mental and emotional energy that takes
that's why i really enjoyed the pandemic
is because i took a break from people
and i'm
just hung out with myself how many
months were you on the road for i know
you're like visiting a bunch of like
national parks and stuff like
six months total maybe five months i was
about four months we actually had like
parallel timelines actually yeah it's
great to be alone and then i i'm happy
to be back in society and i'm not forced
to be here
i know that uh would you ever consider
doing this i know ari is like
known for like
leaving the country and going off the
grid for like three months at a time
would you ever do that
yeah i think it's good for you
but i do like having a career and like
furthering it
um maybe i would do a podcast from the
road so i don't lose any
fans or followers
be easier to podcast if that's like all
you did and no comedy that was
you'd have a lot of time on your hands
yeah
so do you uh
do you date a lot
before you met your girlfriend were you
out there
dating a lot of people i was on the app
so i would like meet girls after shows i
i don't know if you got this but after
shang chi came out that helped asians a
lot i didn't feel anything
i think it's a placebo effect
maybe on the girls i don't think it
helped i didn't i didn't act any
different but i
i had like six cougars come up to me
like within a month after shane she came
out and i was like i cannot wait for the
sequel
what the
15 rings
it's just like what kind of people are
these
[ __ ] that are changing their whole
sexual preference based on what marvel
movie comes out next great that's fine
with me
dumbest people that's who you're
attracting just watch you're going to be
in the next shanghai man you're going to
be a sidekick and you'll be
like i love marvel like you couldn't see
the humanity in asian people before a
marvel movie that wasn't even that good
came out that didn't really delve into
asian culture
that much
it takes hollywood to get you laid
sometimes
bruce lee kind of painted the way gently
jackie chan didn't really help honestly
too goofy
yeah he was asexual
um yeah i mean i think that uh
maybe it was the chicken and the egg you
know maybe asian people were accepted in
mainstream society and then they made a
movie about it rather than the other way
around because asian women have been
doing great and they don't have any
marvel movies that's true but they're
also like sexualized and in like a very
negative way it's where they're like
fetishized
i mean that's how
uh
american culture treats anything that
they want to [ __ ]
it's not like the asians that are the
problem but like sex so
at least they're in there at least
they're
in the in the [ __ ] game
now we just have to improve our general
sexual health as a culture
i mean as a kill tony regular you
basically are like a billboard for
yellow fever you're like promoting
asians
to mainly a white audience
yeah i mean
asians aren't really that well
represented so that's good
um
yeah i mean i'm just like trying to be a
normal person
um
yeah it's not really that hard
so uh what do you think you think like
it's good that i'm killed have you been
helped out by that
not really i i guess my the only benefit
from you being on kill tony is that i've
been mistaken for you several times yeah
that's like helped me helping you out
[Laughter]
at least you're confused with a real
person that is actually doing something
and not just a fake movie about a dude
that doesn't exist with powers that
aren't real
i think i i wouldn't mind being mixed up
for shang chi
um i think that uh
it's fine to if you like
marvel movies it's just like to me
that's like the i mean
it's like such a shitty art in a
nutshell
yeah it's like mad libs
mad libs in what way that's interesting
like put in race here and then put in
superpower here put in the love interest
here and then uh family dynamics here
but yeah i mean i think the thing about
the asian movies that came out like
shanghai and everything everywhere all
at once is that they're really good at
painting inter generational
uh
conflict
i think asians are very much more aware
of that
because like everything everywhere all
at once is all about that shang chi was
about like a dad that's like lost his
way
like a boomer that's just
hell bent on power and the millennial
has to come in and be like
to conscious everything yeah stop being
so crazy
that's interesting that would resonate
with a lot of asians especially because
that that hits home for other audiences
maybe not as much
yeah because we're just like so mired in
it we're like our parents are like this
but i'm like this
dude that's half-life i just talk about
like it's all inspired by like family
and like rifts
apart from the family
well i don't really
um you know i don't really fight with my
family or interact with them i just
ignore them and then like deal with the
problems
that exist
outside of my family
but maybe the family is a good way to
tackle the problem
i don't know if you felt this
but when i was like on my road trip
around the same time as you like it was
the first time i was like off the grid i
didn't talk to family for essentially
like four months
and i was like it was the happiest i've
ever been and i was like what is this
telling me
i think it just means you needed a break
and you just needed to be by yourself
but if you're by yourself for a long
time maybe you would crave other people
no you definitely do yeah just even like
a on a three day like solo like
backpacking trip you'll feel it you
don't want to talk to like yeah it's
like everything you do
is amazing and great but there's no
context and there's no
if you if there's no one there watching
you do it then it's like it doesn't even
matter
it might as well not have happened
because there's no one there to give it
meaning or
tell you
uh
how how awesome that was right
yeah like i loved
like my sleep schedule was so good when
i was living out there because you wake
up with the sun yeah i woke up before
the sunrise and i would like get on top
of a hill
and wait for the sun to rise
and just see
the sun rising and the shadows moving
it's really cool it's really good for
you i think
sleep like the quality of sleep you can
definitely feel it like when you go to
bed at like
10 or 11 p.m which is kind of early for
like comedians especially
that
[ __ ] what was i going to say this white
closet it's good for you to sleep on
time and you sleep at 10 or 11 it you
probably sleep better yeah
i don't know if you felt this but like
the biggest pain in the ass with camping
is finding shade during the day
like i i would enjoy sunrise and then
from like 10 30 until like 6 p.m it
would suck ass
because it was so sunny yeah
no matter where i was
yeah i mean you got to find uh you got
to go at the right time
the weather is so important the season
i love uh i loved camping when i did i
camped like december in southern
california damn which is perfect yeah
yeah did you go to death valley
uh no i was in joshua tree
but yeah i love camping we should go
sometime i'd be down what's the
what's the best spot around here
i don't know they're all paid spots
i went to kiko's property
i heard that's a good spot it's on the
water right yeah but it's like a
neighborhood it's not really like a camp
spot but it's pretty remote
and there's like
a
rv park and there's like a there's like
a bunch of people on the river it's not
really secluded but
it's still it's still sort of like
camping
but yeah we'd have to pay for a spot
which i think is [ __ ]
why should i pay to go camping the whole
thing is like i don't need anything yeah
if there's like running water and wi-fi
then maybe i'd pay for it
but yeah i just don't know why i don't
need anything like you don't need to do
any upkeep you don't need to rake the
the sand
just let me go out like it's so crazy
that we have to pay for camping
you have to pay to go to joshua street
right
if you wanted to go into joshua tree
yeah but i
was like in the blm lands above and
below joshua dude blm man they
they deserve a lot of credit like it's
so awesome dude
yeah it's just free
and then they take care of everything
yeah also black lives matter blm twice
yeah not a lot of people know about blm
in texas because they have no public
lands here everything is private it's
all oil
soft branches
and ranges they're just like let's let
the rich people have whatever they want
here nothing for the public all for the
private
a part of me is like that's kind of fine
because texas really doesn't have that
many great parks or like lands like if
you go to like well which came first the
chicken or the egg
maybe there aren't a lot of great parks
and lands because we didn't build them
no but the whole idea of a national park
is that it's like naturally
appealing and beautiful like joshua
maybe
maybe there was beautiful [ __ ] here but
then it's all in private hands
i'm sure there's a lot of beautiful
places like the hill country here
then there's like the desert there's
like different things going on here
i've driven through texas so many times
there's nothing hans you're an optimist
in this situation but there's nothing
dude i've driven out to big ben twice
there's nothing man joshua tree isn't
that great
i don't know a bunch of cacti yeah
death valley is great though you should
have gone there
it was pretty cold
it gets pretty cold in death valley it
definitely does i was there in the
summer like during the hottest month at
night it'd be 110 degrees how did you
sleep did you were you in a tent no i
was in a truck dude it was [ __ ]
terrible that's horrible
did you have ac did you leave your car
running no no i was just sweating
through the night i left all the windows
down i slept with the machete
it was terrible dude i was there for
five days
oh my god dude
you're crazy
uh that's fun
five days of heat
yeah you gotta pick the right time to go
camping that's i'm not going camping now
in texas
and it's also like i don't want to
travel far i'm like such as i'm such a
spoiled little baby about camping ever
since i've been camping same i just
needed to be perfect or else i'm not
going
i'd be willing to get a trip going out
with a couple other comics but like you
gotta
fall is the perfect time to go honestly
yeah like october that would be perfect
yeah it's coming up september already i
know dude 911's around the corner
yeah i can't wait let's celebrate by
running into buildings
no there's enough dark comedy shows on 9
11. you can solve right there we should
go uh base jumping off of a skyscraper
to imitate the people that were jumping
off of
the building
um
yeah i mean texas is pretty barren
but this west or east texas is great
west texas is horrible i haven't been to
the east that much what have you seen
we're in the east
like the green if you look at a map of
texas on google maps it's just all green
and then on the west side it's all brown
it's just desert
yeah
the thing about uh
the fall is that's when all the legals
will be coming around
but they come from the south if we go
east that's fine well who knows where
they're going to be coming out from
do you think that
who who would you bring camping with you
damn that's a good question
matt boyd he's a handyman he's an
outdoorsy guy
he also doesn't eat a lot of food
he's very small
he's efficient
he's the most amount of conversation for
the least amount of nutrients
he's fun size we'll we'll we'll make him
carry all the fruit that's the heaviest
stuff
uh i went camping with this girl and she
was doing dishes
like
like she she was living in a car too and
she had like a bunch of china she had
like uh
like
like a kayak and like
just a bunch of random ass [ __ ] just
shoved into her car
and i was like this is not efficient
definitely stole it
maybe but yeah we were like camping and
we had like
not that much fresh water and she's like
using it to clean the dishes
for this china
this glassware i was like what are you
doing
but yeah i mean as long as she's having
fun that's the thing it's like it gets
so boring out there like if you if you
find a project and you want to do it and
someone tells you no there's like
[ __ ] you i want to do this
wait so you weren't staying in the car
you were like straight up just like only
a backpack and no i was just staying in
the van oh
oh
water is a problem
well yeah i mean it wasn't a problem it
was just like now we're gonna have to go
back into town to get water
but yeah i mean
i enjoyed not going back into town but
she was like let's go to walmart i need
more [ __ ]
it's like a girl thing too yeah like
they like feeling connected and safe and
luxurious
did you make them feel safe
i hope so protected
i mean i didn't have a gun but i had a
oh i didn't even have a spear i was
making a spear i found like a metal pole
and i would heat it up in the campfire
and then rub it on
a rock
and i still have it
you made like a
shank basically yeah like a javelin
shank yeah
it's not a very good
spear
because i just flattened it and then
made it pointy but it's like these two
things
so i just
combine them together
i still have it is it in your room it's
in my van
perfect i got a real spear on amazon
they're only like 50 bucks really yeah
are they like the one of the javelin
spears that you could throw
i i'm sure you could throw it i don't
think it's meant for throwing though ah
i don't i don't want to throw my spear
because then now it's over there
[Laughter]
but it's the perfect weapon because guns
are hard to use if you're not trained at
it
because you're just standing there while
some guy's coming at you and you gotta
do this
but a spear you can be like
it's more natural to just i've seen
videos of you shooting a gun you seem
fine well now i am yeah i've been
shooting a lot yeah you've been in texas
two years you know what to do yeah
i love it i love shooting guns it's like
you get to play out a fantasy and it's
like practical and it's like a martial
art
it's everything you ever just go to the
target slap on an old bully on the face
no it's at a range so it's kind of weird
so yeah what do you think do you think
that uh
we should talk about dating
sure yeah dude are you on the apps what
are you doing these days
um
i only meet people through comedy
i don't want to meet anyone any other
way because i don't have any advantages
outside of comedy
why would i like play a game that i
don't i'm not good at i got another
yeah i'd rather play
with the dyes dice loaded we've talked
about this a little bit before but like
i feel like kill tony mondays should be
like your holy day right
because you're like a god for like you
mean a day full of holes
yeah
yeah i mean i'm more popular on mondays
usually um
kill tony helps
i have a girl right now in san antonio
and we've been seeing each other and
she's amazing
um
but yeah like before i met her it was
just like
it's just tricky because like
because like okay so i do kill tony i'm
up first usually i end the show
and then what do you mean you end the
show oh no i don't end the show i the
show ends okay
and then
what do i do i just walk around
like looking for attention and approval
that feels weird
so i usually just spend it in the green
room hanging with the guests and tony
and william montgomery and just having a
good time just shooting the [ __ ] and
then eventually i go out but by then
everyone's gone
uh so and then i go to continental club
and hang out there oh that's a great
club yeah
you've been there before the pandemic
no
after the pandemic i try to run a couple
shows there but i just like stayed there
to catch a couple shows it's a great
place i'm definitely hanging out there
it's a really good place
yeah it's a good place i meet some
people there sometimes
do you go solo or do you go out with
people i mean i go there with the kill
tony crew nice
so
um yeah i uh i don't like to go anywhere
where i i'm not known or where i don't
have an advantage
and like this x of mine was like
saying that like a net bad thing she's
like you don't like to go out you only
like to go out where people know you i
was like yeah obviously i like that i
love how you use advantage almost like
this is all like a monopoly game i love
it dude yeah so i only go to
places where i can collect two hundred
dollars
uh where i uh
yeah
yeah i mean
i don't think like the normal dating
scene is like the objective truth and
like the best way to date
i think that [ __ ] is all [ __ ] up so i
don't respect that game and if i don't
have to play it i won't
i don't think that it's a healthy way to
meet people and i don't like the way
that the people treat me
unless they know me like if they don't
know me they treat me like [ __ ]
and
i don't want to deal with that like
it's either you accept being treated
like [ __ ] or you fight back
and fighting back
even if you win it just makes you look
like an [ __ ] and yeah
yeah so what are you looking for with
dating do you want a girlfriend do you
want like uh yeah [ __ ] buddy i want a
girlfriend i want someone who will be
there for a long time that
i'm happy
to be seen in public with that i like
showing off
i've seen the last two girls you were
with i met your your blonde uh gal foul
she's very pretty
thanks
but yeah i mean that's a part of it but
it's obviously not the end-all be-all
but yeah it's important to you know not
be ashamed of the person that you love
um and to like brag and show off look
what i can do
i'm awesome but that's like that you
can't like
live off of that that's a very shallow
that's like dessert
um but yeah if i think that she's pretty
then that's more important
because you're gonna be happy to see
that every day
but yeah i don't i like to uh have a
girlfriend like a steady and like
someone who isn't gonna just run away
and like i have to start over and find
someone new all the time
that's exhausting i'd rather just you
know have a relationship with someone
and like build
uh you know build on top
of instead of just having shallow
one-time reactions yeah i feel like it's
even harder for you to date because the
people know you do kill tony you open
for rogan now like do you feel like
dating is harder
no it's way easier people are more like
finding like a genuine connection i'm
sure they're interested but like
to differentiate like filter out the
girls who i don't think like most people
are like most people are aware that
that could be a possibility and then
they try to censor themselves and most
people who
are like that are very easy to spot
most people are like oh yeah i know he
does that but that's not the most
important thing
even though that is like a definite
benefit it definitely improves my
quality of life
to open for rogan and have money and do
cool [ __ ]
and have cool experiences
but yeah i don't like going out in
public and meeting randos i just feel
like people are so suspicious and wary
especially women
single women they're like gross you want
to have sex with me that's perverted
it's like relax you [ __ ] puritan in
europe they're so much more relaxed
about all that like people actually smug
girls actually smile at you and they
don't make you feel bad for wanting to
[ __ ] them
sex is like very normalized over there
over here like
you shouldn't care if the girl has sex
with like 40 guys who gives a [ __ ]
yeah
yeah have fun
uh have a good time but yeah i mean i
think like uh
it's our puritan background like we're
founded by the most religious freaks and
weirdos and we
did alcohol prohibition and we just have
a lot of like prudes and stuck up
you know like a lot of people that don't
like sex
in our in our history and also i think
it's like our lack of social safety net
and health care like women need a [ __ ]
to survive
like in europe they have a social safety
net but here it's like if you [ __ ] the
wrong person you could be in a trailer
sorry interesting so it's more serious
it's not fun it's more like business
like stop staring at me
i need to use my sexuality to
get a a decent standard of living and
you're [ __ ] it up for me it's like
yeah it's like not fun it's more like a
business
yeah and girls are running against the
clock too so it's even more like a
business
yeah
when the when they have the least
patience too when they're young and want
to have fun that's when they have the
most market value
and they they're that that's the
juxtaposition they're like i want to
just have fun but i also need to make
sure when i'm 40 that i'm not living in
the streets
so i need to find the right guy no you
got to find the right girl who's like
independent a girl who like pays for her
own [ __ ]
yeah that would help
but even if you find a girl like that
they're probably like [ __ ] because
they have to work so hard to get there
they're like they're type a yeah
like uh i've noticed dating in new york
versus austin the girls in austin are
like yeah you can pay for it girls in
new york type a they're like no i want
to pay for this latte yeah well it's
more even over there
yeah
men and women make roughly the same
amount over there as opposed to here
[Music]
remember pearl harbor
that's coming up soon too yeah pearl
harbor one asians owned white people
that's the asian 911 right there that's
the asian d-day
that's our finest moment
but honestly japanese people kind of
[ __ ] up everybody they [ __ ] up the
philippines they were really bad
they were really in a bad mood during
the four years i i had fun when i
visited japan twice i will say though my
grandpa or my grandma
was
she knew people who were like survive
the rape of nanjing
and she like
she even like saw somebody like get cut
in half
that'll put a
damper on your japan trip
yeah i didn't find out after i left
japan thank god but yeah i was like
that's pretty [ __ ] up then they went
from like cutting women in half by the
[ __ ] to a hello kitty
and making some of the best porn ever
you think it's good porn i don't think
it's good they censor everything you
kidding me dude i know even with the
censorship you can find some good [ __ ]
because
that's it that's all they got they have
like [ __ ] like their standard big
name porn isn't that great but like some
of the mental games and like the
seduction that goes on
because they did some [ __ ] up [ __ ]
what you're talking about like the new
rules like massage porn
um
because they [ __ ] drug girls
to make them super horny and then they
start touching their [ __ ]
and it's like super hot because it's
like they didn't expect it and then
they're getting a finger in their [ __ ]
it's like what kind of drunky rape like
horny drugs i don't know what it is it
makes girls horny yeah i might take some
myself i know i need to find this
because uh that might be the next thing
next time y'all watch the podcast it'll
be sponsored by horny drugs
they're a good bdsm
you like that i can't i can't even do
that i just feel like you haven't found
the right stuff
like there's some good japanese porn uh
send me a couple links after this
i'll show you what i
came to recently
um but yeah i love [ __ ] i i don't
respect like the game of [ __ ] and like
the people that actually
get a lot of [ __ ] so to me it's like
just a joke like hahaha
you know i get a lot of puss like i want
i want to disrespect that game and i
want people that play that game
seriously to be ridiculed and made fun
of
because i think it's
a hoax i think you don't reward the
right people girls have no idea who to
[ __ ] or who not to and they always [ __ ]
the wrong people and the people that
they should [ __ ] are lonely and
sad and girls never make an effort to go
out and meet people and they complain
that everyone in their life is pushy and
aggressive
i can never find the right guy
yeah
that's because they are looking for
someone that just overwhelms all their
senses they're like holy [ __ ] this guy
is like doing [ __ ] i can't even
process he must be good for me it's like
they have no like taste they just want
like
you know overwhelming
sensations and they have no like
discerning
discernment
they just want someone that's like gonna
[ __ ] their [ __ ] up and not someone who's
like
takes a while to understand and like
it's like an acquired taste and you
develop together and you have
exponential
uh returns on pleasure
because they're just too impatient
they're just
yeah they're just
uh like tick-tock generation they just
want every everything the most possible
they don't want to work for it at all
talk generally are you talking to like
17 year old girls we're more like
talking about millennials yeah i mean
them too but tick tock is the worst
version of that yeah and like there's
less sex going on now
i'm saying that
then people are eating ass now who's
saying well they're doing more extreme
[ __ ]
but i think people nowadays are too
self-centered
to [ __ ] because [ __ ] requires you to
think about another person
they've never really thought about other
people
they only care about themselves
did you feel like i i feel this at least
let me know what you think i feel like
girls in new york were more horny but
girls in austin are hotter
i mean new york has some of the hottest
girls ever
maybe just like the general popular on
average
um
are hornier i guess because it's more
liberal there they feel safer and
they're like more willing to
but sex is also like connectivity to
like offset anxiety and depression too i
think yeah it's all about like their
self-care
yeah i'm just gonna [ __ ] someone to make
myself feel better but here it's like
all about reputation and they don't want
to be known as a [ __ ]
yeah especially because austin is like a
relatively small city it's like a
million people it's
it's not that big yeah
yeah it's a small city
um and people here are closer
they're more nice like people like get
nicer to each other right away as
opposed to in new york there's like a
wall
they're like oh you're just another
person
and then you have to break past that but
here they're like oh look another person
like people are more valuable here
in new york they're just like another
human being that i have to ignore
people get really good at ignoring and
finding ways to like relegate someone to
the outskirts of their of their personal
life in new york just because they have
to do it all the time
so it's like
you can see it like
when you talk to someone in new york
like they don't even like pay attention
to you fully they're just like on
autopilot
because like they don't give a [ __ ]
really yeah
although there's something to be said
about that everybody is like that but
like do you find like moments of
vulnerability i think to where like
there's so many people eager for
connection
not just sexual just like the idea of
like making a new friend
yeah because it's like they see people
all the time and then they they're like
oh i should connect i wish i could
connect and then finally they find
someone they can connect to
but the weird thing in new york is that
uh a friendship kind of fizzles out like
if you see somebody in new york like
once a month that's like a steady buddy
that only happens for like five months
but in austin you can keep that going
like pretty regularly
yeah
yeah because everyone's
yeah there's so many people in new york
you can just find a replacement
nah dude we're replaceable in new york
yeah
that's the thing is like if you feel
replaceable and you don't know what's
valuable about yourself and a lot of the
comics there are like fighting against
relevancy and like
they're like don't forget about me
so they do like shocking things and
things to get remembered sometimes
and sometimes they just are like boring
like they're just like yeah i'm just
another person don't mind me all right
that's every white comic that's what i
don't like man they're all so
self-deprecating yes it's always
so much of it is the same
well don't you think asians are more
self-deprecating i don't think so no
actually i can't really base there's not
that many asian comics but like
ronnie chang jimmy jimmy yang they're
not that self-deprecating i guess not i
mean they tap into the black culture
thing about like bragging
yeah yeah dude you got to go the
opposite direction if everybody thinks
asians are meek go the opposite then
like uplift asia that's kind of what i
do
that's why i have wrote so many yellow
figure jokes
i mean i just don't try to like
boost myself up or put myself down i
just do whatever it takes to get that
laugh like i'll do either i don't i'm
not married to one or the other
but yeah i don't uh
i don't i don't
buy into the whole you got to have
confidence and the more confidence you
have the better you are like i don't
give a [ __ ] i think it's better to be
successful without confidence than to be
confident and then find success
because then you have to like bluff your
way there
and it's like that's not what real funny
or real humor real success or real
winning is about it's not about
confidence it's about doing what you
have to do to get the win
like basketball is about shooting the
basket it's not about having confidence
so if i can get the ball in the hoop
without your version of confidence and
without the appearance of confidence
then i am more satisfied with that
victory because i didn't have to buy
into your
shitty
culture
to
succeed
so
that's interesting because i feel like
right now with podcast blowing up
everybody's got a youtube special
comedians are kind of like being blown
into like uh kind of being compared to
like rock stars so that comes with like
the confidence and so that's what people
expect so when they see somebody who's
like not deadpan but like more
conversational like you it like
contrasts with their expectations
they're like i thought every convenience
like a rock star they go out like this
and they're like [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
crutch
yeah
yeah but it doesn't work in comedy it's
hard to be a braggart
and like a arrogant person it works in
rap but in comedy it's just like
off-putting
because there's no music there's no
feeling it's just thoughts and only
thought is i'm the best which is
obviously not true unless you're like
joe brogan
but even he's not arrogant he like
he has to
do his comedy despite the fact that he's
famous it seems like more than
bragging about it and leaning into it
he's like just funny
you know even though he's famous yeah
does that show that you're still a
normal guy yeah it's just not a good
thought that i'm the best
like it's because it's obviously not
true and then i think you have to
respect humans now if you do comedy then
you respect the audience and you respect
the collective
and you don't just ignore them and just
say that they're idiots
no that's what i hate the most man i
would never book a comic if i see them
on stage even at a mic just being like
y'all you all decided to just stay for
this
you all paid money to see this show
god damn i hate that yeah it's like so
uh
against what you're supposed to do
they're like i'm gonna do exactly what
i'm not supposed to do but some things
like you don't have to do
that like just to break the mold like
you should be breaking the mold for a
reason not just to break the mold and
they're just like all just like anti
whatever is going on instead of like
they don't have like a a message they
just are against a bunch of things
so what do you think do you think that
we should radically reshape
our society
i don't know what to do man besides keep
on telling dick jokes
that's where the nihilism comes into
play i'm just like have fun and then
don't be an [ __ ]
so how do you have fun
comedy try to make three friends keep
sniffing this
friends and what timeline
good question end of the year
end of the year i got my girlfriend
that's one three new friends one and a
half huh three new friends yeah or like
three close friends three close friends
i get i have like maybe four close
friends already but i don't see them as
often because they're they're other
places
yeah friends that you don't hang out
with all the time are barely friends
i don't even i don't like keeping up
with people via text yeah you can't dude
yeah it's like you gotta be here
i don't give a [ __ ] if you aren't here
then what kind of friend are you you're
not even coming to hang out uh to people
in new york
not really i don't talk to anyone i hate
text messaging people
it's just a chore that's why whenever i
hear like
comics talking about like yeah i'm still
good friends with this guy
who lives in la we chat all the time i'm
like how do you build that relationship
and like sustain yeah
i would love to it's so helpful like if
you go visit
yeah and you have like a large group of
friends
but yeah i mean i never really do that i
should though i think it's a powerful
tool i just i'm not good at it
i just
it's just a chore for me it's not fun
a lot of it is just
like small talk until you get to a good
punch line
and it takes just too much effort yeah
sometimes it does feel like a circle
jerk to where it's like why are we
trying to jerk each other off
yeah i would rather much i would much
rather talk to someone that i can
talk to in person
and also like girls i'd rather talk to a
girl that is physically
[ __ ]
what the hell do you mean like someone
is like 500
someone who's like 500 miles away it's
like why are we even talking why are you
talking to them in the first place
exactly that's what i'm saying
okay good i thought your like hinge and
tinder settings were up to like 500
miles i was like no dude same
neighborhood half a mile i think uh
girls like doing that because it's like
a game it's like let me just play the
game of dating
without any consequences
but yeah unless there's consequences
that it's not fun
unless we could actually [ __ ]
then what is the point it's like [ __ ]
playing basketball without any net
without a hoop
i uh
yeah i just think that uh
there's so much waiting around and doing
nothing and dating anyways i don't need
to like
simulate that with a far away date
there's plenty of dates that go nowhere
what's the worst date you've been on
worst date i've been on was in seattle
like five years ago
and it was like a girl who was very
overweight
uh we met at this
vegan coffee shop and she made me take
the briggs myers test
no
dude what the [ __ ] i was so horny i was
like
such a [ __ ] loser and i did the whole
briggs myers test with her and i found
out i'm uh whatever some [ __ ] i
don't even believe in that [ __ ]
and then we went to
the locks
it's like a damn or like fish go and
then she was like playing pokemon go
she was like addicted to pokemon go
and we were in the middle of a date she
was playing pokemon go i was latched on
to her like on her side just like
kissing her
and she was playing pokemon go
and then i made out with her and then i
texted her sorry i don't think we should
date anymore and she's like you should
have told me that when we met i was like
what are you just trying to hook up with
her and then bounce
well she didn't want she had fat fat
people mentality
or she's like all about her pleasures
and it's all about me no stop doing that
we're doing what i'm doing asian or
white white
yeah that was the first and only date
and she was mad at me because
i let her on apparently
but uh well that honestly that date went
better than i thought i thought when
she told you to take the personality
test
she'd be like oh you're an intj get the
[ __ ] out of here
it was so long it took forever
and it was just her asking me questions
and it was like [ __ ] let's just talk
like you you don't get to know people
with some [ __ ] industrial tests do it
on a phone or a laptop she had it on in
her phone she asked me the question oh
my god
but yeah i mean it's like such an
artificial way to get to know someone
it's like oh this she says you're this
kind of person why don't you just
actually talk to me
but yeah i don't believe in briggs
meyers or
any personality test i think it's just
like a shitty
shitty way to get to know someone dude
she makes you take the personality test
you make her take a bmi test you gotta
know what you're dealing with
you're pre-diabetic
um but yeah i was on this other date
where i met up with this girl a bunch of
times we just hung out and stuff and she
didn't even kiss me
she
no
that's why
well i shouldn't have to
well it should be a mutual thing
uh but it was just like she just wanted
to hang out
it was disgusting i did have a girl like
that too yeah
yeah
it's like what are you getting out of
this like this is not how anyone well
how old was that girl who just wanted to
hang out my age she's like 28.
[Music]
it's just like so slow and so neurotic
and all you're thinking is like how am i
gonna get laid tonight that's an
important part of it
they say split view screen dual camera
one behind each of them i did that last
time and
people didn't like it i like this way
because it's like you see everything's
what the conversation looks like even
though you can only see half of our
faces
all right we'll lean this way
we don't have to
yeah i like i like it doing doing it
this way the split screen is kind of
weird because then it you don't really
get a clear sense of what kind of room
we're sitting in and what's going on you
don't get to see the full hexagons
yeah
i have a green screen we could use
yeah definitely use that next time why
you don't want to make it look like
we're doing the podcast at mar-a-lago
it's just too distracting and then it
takes like you got to set it up and then
i don't know
we can do it
but yeah what's the worst date you've
been on
uh let's see it was in new york and we
met through hinge this girl
said she was uh i'm 11 but i said i was
six one
and then this girl said she was
five nine
but we met
and we like we met at eye level and we
were like you
both looked at each other like you
[ __ ] liar
so i was like started off with distrust
already
so you lied about being taller and she
lied about being shorter yeah we met
right at the middle dude
oh my god you guys are the exact same
height lying to each other
she looked pretty but like man sheila is
like such a hard ass i told her i was
just straight up with her i was like i
just i i'm starting in comedy right now
she's like i don't like comedy i was
like well [ __ ] this you're not gonna
like i don't like comedy that's like if
you're doing improv and someone's like
i'm a tree and someone's like no you're
not yeah it's like there's no way to
recover from that
on a date like you don't say no
like even if you hate comedy you're like
oh cool
have you i like
this one comedy that i saw a lot like
you try to search in your brain for some
positive thing but if you say no i don't
know what the [ __ ] you've been through
like i can't tell you what a positive
memory you have even like an orphan who
was raped has a sense of humor that
[ __ ] like rode horses from washington
dc yeah god damn who the [ __ ] hates
comedy that's like hating
happiness
she smiled like twice during the date
and i was like she was like such a
narcissist dude and then what's even
worse is that i try to embrace like
living in new york doing spontaneous
[ __ ] this guy came up to us hammered and
he was like hey guys i'm black out but i
i got uh
i got courtside tickets to
the next game
y'all want to go and i was like i kind
of do want to but i want to ditch this
[ __ ]
but she came along
you got courtside seats for next game
yeah
from a homeless guy no no the guy who's
at the bar he was hammered and he's like
i can't make it and so he just helped
your date out
he tried to i think honestly he noticed
how awkward it was and he's like i think
it'd be funny if i did that
if i made this day continue yeah
basically that was like the worst four
hours of my life dude so you went on
this thing
yeah we went set courtside it was
amazing
um how much are the tickets tickets
courtside's like
probably like eight
sold you them for how much he paid he
gave it to us free oh [ __ ] that's the
wild part dude yeah that would have been
a great day yeah should have been what
was she like finding negative things
like these seats are too close
no dude i would just like keep trying to
check was she happy at the basketball
game no she wasn't she's just miserable
everywhere no she's like hates comedy i
love basketball and i was like it
doesn't feel like a [ __ ]
yeah i mean some girls are just like you
see this like comedy shows you go to a
comedy show and there's some guy in the
audience just like having the worst time
ever because they're like you're the
comedian make me feel good i'm gonna be
in the worst mood possible so i get the
highest
rise up but it's like you also have to
be in a good mood i can't just make you
in a good mood and that's i feel like
some girls are like
i'm just gonna be miserable and let's
see if this guy can handle me at my
worst
it's just like such a toxic mentality
and then it's like oh he didn't make me
uh
impossibly happy you're a failure
you're a bad man
because if you were awesome you would
have made me
feel so happy even though i put in
notework myself that's why this exists
man if she had a couple drinks before
she would have been less of a a hassle
or any drug i think alcohol is just
associated with a horny drug
yeah go watch some japanese porn
dude i'm an introvert i i talk
a decent-ish amount but i had to steer
the conversation and then i asked her i
was like
are you an introvert or an extrovert i
knew the [ __ ] answer and she was like
i'm definitely an extrovert
no you're a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] i'm just
extroverted not around you yeah
yeah i mean some people just are in a
bad mood or they
dating is there's a lot going on like
there's a lot of you know
they have they have this idea of who
they are and then you go on a date and
it's like you have to maintain this idea
of who you are yeah
after the date
we just parted ways and i was like don't
forget to drink milk tonight you just
said something stupid yeah because the
whole date was stupid
well that's unfortunate
i know she was cute too too
bad oh she's too tall for you
no you're the same height i would have
been fine with it
well yeah i mean maybe she was just in a
bad mood or maybe that's she's just
gonna go through life just being a
shitty date for everyone and find a dude
who can
put up with
all of her [ __ ]
who's weak enough what's hap what's
gonna happen is she gonna be 34 and
lonely and then pick up the first guy
and then be desperate be
kind on a date for once
but yeah there's so many horny guys that
eventually she's going to find someone
who's going to be able to put up with
that and she's going to [ __ ] him and
then find a way to make it work if she
wants to yeah it'll be work and then
in about seven years i'll get divorced
um yeah i mean i think uh it's not all
women's fault because like men here are
crazy too like
you know they're like
extra aggressive and
you know they're like trying not to get
crushed by the wheels of capitalism and
they have to like be like i'm awesome i
deserve all the basic human rights that
aren't afforded to most of the
population because that's how awesome i
am
so you have to have like this level of
arrogance as a man
because like
if you don't then you're just
resigning yourself to being a homeless
trailer park trailer trash loser yeah
um but yeah i think uh i think it's an
unhealthy environment just because like
men are just hyper violent and
aggressive and women are like trying to
boost their ego by rejecting as many
people as possible
what are you doing now
i'm thinking about my response to that
this is like a tantric
oh [ __ ]
well hopefully you'll come up with a
response
you got a little distracted dude i'm
feeling the white claws right now dude i
told you i'm a lightweight i i barely
you don't have the enzyme to break it
down no i don't your face isn't as red
anymore no after like 40 minutes i
haven't even finished this i know dude
i'm gonna i'm gonna get dui if i finish
this
um
i didn't eat that much
today what do you think about uh
what do you think about all this
what life or this pod
gotta do shrooms and then i'll
reevaluate
so let's just assume that you've done
shrooms or that you're on shrooms now
what do you think that you'd feel
i think i would feel
more connected with the world
my guilt would be alleviated for about
three months
you're killed yeah
what guilt do you have
being a shitty date
i ain't the shitty date she was okay
we'll have to take your word for it
come to a knicks game with me i think
i'll make you smile more than twice
[Laughter]
oh my god i'll be like wow chris is such
a charmer yeah i mean
i don't even have to make him take a
personality test
he's got the blue check mark on me
i don't have a blue check mark dude you
should just apply for it man
you already got like 100k
um
[Music]
yeah i don't know i don't really need it
i'm happy without it um brian redband
doesn't have a blue checkmark
so if he doesn't who am i to
get a plea check mark true
what help with the ladies though
if they say the blue check mark and the
100k and the shangchi
i'm gonna get the most basic dumb ass
[ __ ] that you're always [ __ ]
gonna get chris tan level [ __ ]
and bring smelling salts to a date
oh my god it actually puts thoughts in
my brain for once and no they will look
at this and be like
can you be more subtle about roofing me
what is that deodorant
the little net is so hilarious because
it's like you're never getting out of
here you're just purely for
my cosmetic smell
i just want your essence i don't want
you
whatever the [ __ ] this is
this is so weird dude don't you think
it's like something that someone that
doesn't have like a fully functional
brain does
like makes you feel feel things
like yeah that's what your thoughts are
supposed to do
you've smelled it like 30 times
you're no better you're not better dude
i add it i use it to add i don't use it
to replace i'm using this to enhance
yeah
well what have you what have your
enhancements taught you
um timing on stage has been better
um if i'm
about to drive home drunk this kind of
wakes me up this got me out of like 3d
uis
isn't it crazy that everything is car
based here and then
alcohol is the most common drug
it's like setting yourself up for drunk
driving accidents
and then our roads are trash in austin
somebody said at best they're like
you're not really
a resident of austin until you learn how
to drive after two beers
yeah
you should do that it'll help
uh i think we should have set that up
behind us or something this is doing
nothing yeah i was like why did you put
it over there
i guess maybe at least closer to the
camera
yeah we should turn that light on too on
top of the camera
maybe next time that's fine it's fine
how long have we been going feels like
two and a half
uh one and a half
these boys are two claw crazy
dude i'm like one and a half claw crazy
i'm like
two nails
what is it that you'd like to say to
people if you could get the chance to
tell people something
first off invest in uh
herbal inhalants we we want to start a
trend right hans
that's all you man
fine i'll find your sponsor all right
that's the kind of stuff you do when you
have no
issues in your life you just start
smelling things because you're so bored
i i am getting into cigars after working
with rogan have you gotten into some
cars yet no not really damn i can't
really smoke too much i got a really
sensitive throat
you're giving me [ __ ] about not smoking
weed
yeah i'm glad you didn't want to smoke
weed i'm honestly addicted and it's not
healthy
do you do it before getting up on stage
sometimes
does it help it's uh sometimes it helps
it's both sometimes it helps sometimes
it doesn't
so what do you think about uh
well what i would tell people is like to
not just do what you feel the momentum
of your society is forcing you to do but
do something that is actually natural
and human and like something that you
are feel drawn to
because i feel like if you just do what
you're told and what you're
feel like you're you're forced to do
you're just going to be used as a tool
for people that are going to
use you for their benefit and not your
own
i think you should utilize yourself to
your own benefit and become an enhanced
version of yourself and that will be
actually better for humanity and society
overall
but what do you think message i i agree
with that something that nobody really
talks about is that uh when society kind
of tells you like do this and that
to be happy you got to be selfish and
just say [ __ ] you to the system [ __ ] you
to your boss sometimes even your own
family
happiness you gotta be selfish
yeah but i mean a lot of happiness comes
from helping others
that's what it's
pretty much everything that anyone does
is to help other people hmm
i was just thinking about it from like a
comedy art perspective to where like
there's people who are like no don't do
it but you're like no this is all for me
yeah well you got to help yourself to
help others right you can't be like a
disheveled loser
with no money and try to help other
people yeah how am i gonna make the the
world better without [ __ ] jokes
what do you think about midgets
i don't really see them around that much
i say i say [ __ ] as like a go-to riff
so i'm glad i haven't run into that
situation yet
yeah
i mean
it's just one of those words that people
are like don't say but you know i don't
think that your first uh
i don't think that the best way to gain
empathy for a minority group is to tell
people what to say and what not to say
i think it's like you're gonna have to
pay attention to me and do what i want
because for so long i've been dealing
with your [ __ ]
it's like why don't you just like tell
us something positive about you tell us
something that we can call you instead
of what we can't call you
like
what are your thoughts on uh bbw
big beautiful woman yeah you're a black
beautiful woman
big women i think like a lot of people
are have shitty diets and they uh come
from a
a a time when we didn't know much about
nutrition so it's not always their fault
and especially if you're like uh
not white or asian
if you're like you know mexican or black
like you're not designed to handle
the amount of sugar that we have in our
diet so
i think a lot of minorities are
disproportionately affected by obesity
so i don't i try not to blame people
but i think it's also wrong to just be
like yeah you're beautiful no matter how
unhealthy you are i think it's like no
this is
a sad reality that it's not their fault
but they're fat and it's not good
and it just takes a lot of
sort of uh
intellectual power to just be like
understand the world for what it is
instead of like thinking about it in a
way that makes you feel better
but some people are just fat because
they overeat and they're stupid
i used to be a fat kid i wish the uh
the fat loving movement was a thing back
in like 2008 it wouldn't have been much
better for you
even if you're
in the fat loving people know in the
back of their minds that you're
undesirable yeah
it's just like a sugar coating over it
so how i mean isn't that good to be a
fat kid because then you grow up like
kids aren't supposed to be
hot
you're just supposed to be whatever you
are to get ahead
like you're you're a cat ear like a
cocoon like this isn't your final form
you don't want to waste all your marbles
being a hot kid and end up being an ugly
adult
you're just
in the middle stages so you have to
be whatever you have to be to be hot
later
but how fat were you
i was thirteen
five six seven
and
195 pounds
you weren't that fat you were a fat
friend asian
but
the whole reason why i lost weight is
because my doctor was like dude if you
gain more weight you're going to get
diabetes
what were you eating
decently healthy food not too much soda
or sweets so why were you so fat then
because i would eat like five meals a
day
meals it's just no snacks it's just like
the amount of food you were eating yeah
why did you eat so much i think cause i
was unhappy i went to a school with a
bunch of white kids
so you're dealing with your problems by
eating probably that's what my therapist
told me i was like no it's because my
family works at a grocery store
so you have access you have a supply
basically you got high on your own
supply
that's funny
so what do you think it was
[Music]
maybe a lack of friends growing up in
elementary school perhaps i also think
there is a big temptation with food at
home
so it's a chicken in the egg situation
so you your family is overeaters no just
me when i was a kid there's no other fat
kids
well that's crazy that you just became
fat through like sheer
amount of food
instead of like the type of food yeah i
remember my family would go to like a
buffet
and
i would always like take two cookies to
go
and then i tried to like start losing
weight and i was like you know what
i'm on a diet now i'm only take one
cookie
[Laughter]
so do you think that made you more like
self-confident and like more into your
own self because you're like
there was like a voice that you're
fighting in your own
head and no one else wanted to play with
you and so you're just like you have to
create your own world
you have to create your own
dialogue and narration yeah i talk to
myself a lot even now
but uh yeah
i thought losing weight would have
gotten me more girls did not help at all
made no difference
yeah what did help get girls
waiting for crazy rich asians to come
out
what is with you and following cultural
trends it helps man
i also guess that helps i think just not
going to a school full of white people
helps a lot
yeah
you like diversity you like people that
come from your cultural background
no i don't like diversity i like only
asians
really
you're so weird i don't think you'd do
well with asians they'd be like why are
you so different no american asians like
us that's different i grew up only with
white kids and then i went to college
and i made friends with like american
born asians and i was like holy [ __ ]
where have you been yeah it's important
because like asians
are kind of stuck up and they're like
they don't asian asian or asian american
asians um and then white people are just
like they're they're unaware they're
like they only think about themselves
they're like ah they're always yelling
and doing whatever the [ __ ] they want to
do but asian americans are like sort of
in the middle they're like
uh they're thinking about [ __ ] and
they're like observing and they're
noticing things that you know
self-centered
uh selfish americans would never notice
but they're also like into having fun
and like free
in a way that asians aren't because
they're like worried about their grades
or like you know
they're they're not really looking to
have a good time they're really more
looking to have like uh tangible results
like money or something
yeah i think our generation especially
if you're like
around 30 even younger
that
i think is the you have the good
qualities of being asian but also the
good qualities of being an american to
where like free-willed entrepreneurial
asian just like smart hard-working so
melded together yeah
if only we lived in a meritocracy
dude i wish man i wish
yeah i mean i think it's a good way to
go even if it's not beneficial it's
still like the best way to be
i'd rather be that way than any other
way
sort of aware
and not just like clueless
and unaware
um
so you want to call it a podcast yeah
yeah sounds good let's see if there's
any good comments to end on
new york washington
diet coke you should write a book
kids book tubbing
tubbins
get type 2. harriet tubman getting type
2 i don't know
a lot of hot chocolate
oh you're just like tubbins truth is
more painful
there's nothing good have you looked
like the cat
hans you look like the carrot cake my
grandma made for me last wednesday
it's very specific was it like an oval
round
carrot cake
anyways she's calling you trump you you
look orange anything you want to say
uh
yellow fever
long lives
yes start [ __ ] asian guys we're not
that bad
we're part of the